I'm getting excited and it's okay I'll do it all the time What's the crime?
Asta-san who's hunching over is cute too.As you
said, first of all, let's figure out each other's abilities and start creating.The
enemy team will also do the same.  It should be big
I have 3 swords I'm good at recovery and support plant magic
Mr. Aster demonstrates his power in close range combat
Mr. Anti-Magic of magic nullification What kind of ah
tan brother
Enemy team
I don't think it's possible to get crystal chicks out so quickly, but it's
probably because of the variable distance
.
Well, I'll close my visit to the United States, drink Quatch, and have a chance to play an active role in the
meantime, isn't that right?
Let me tell you what is
it?
Hey, is it
lack of sleep or is it a
strategy